so californium is another element which
was first prepared at the Berkeley labs
in California it's got quite a few
military applications usually involving
the word nuclear but what most people
don't realize is it's actually used in
various types of machines for detecting
metal fatigue and stress in airplanes so
obviously it's pretty important our
planes don't fold bits in midair and
they're used in the kind of instruments
which scan for this and can spot any
problems long before they become a
serious issue it's also probably the
only other actinide which is possibly
routinely got its way into households
which is that it's also used in metal
detectors